يسعد صباحكم جميعا نحن هنا في مطعم الشيف
محمد علي طالبي الذي تركه وغادر نحو
الطبيعه غادر نحو الطبيعه الخلابه من اجل
اعداد الاطباق الجميله واللذيذه محمد علي
طالبي او دور هكذا يعرفه الناس على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي كيف خطرت ببالك هذه
الفكره وهذه المغامره اولا
صباح ارجاء العالم العربي الفكره الحقيقه
من زمن الكورونا ربه ذره نافعه
نمشي نعمل حاجات انا مغروم بها الحقيقه من
قبل التصوير والميدان نتاعي هو الطبخ دونك
قلت علاش لا ما نمشيوش نعملوا محتوى
المطبخ في الطبيعه محتوى المطبخ في
الطبيعه هو الشيء الذي اشتهر به دليل
وغادر مطعمه من اجل ان يلاحق هذا الحلم ما
هي المصاعب التي اعترضتك محمد علي طالبي
من اجل ان تؤسس دلي اودور وان تترك المطعم
الخاص بك وتترك الحرفاء وتترك الاستقرار
والاريحيه من اجل ان ربما تلاحق حلم فيه
عديد المسار الحقيقه هو الهدف الاولاني هو
خلينا خلينا نعرفه بتونس والطبيعه الخالبه
متاعها فيها البحر فيها الطبيعه بتحمله
الكلمه بمعنى الجبال الصحراء من غديك جات
الفكره نمشي ونوريه للعالم في الغرب
المطبخ العربي اللي هو من ضمنه تونس
المصاعب كثيره الحقيقه تبدا تصور باش
تستعمل النار اللي هي الموقد الطبيعي كيما
كيما في القديم وتحاول ترتجل ساعه تبدا
فما حاجه
يصير فيما برشر الصعوبات وساعات تعترضك
الحيوانات منهم اخر حلقه في
جبال عين دراهم تصاورت معايا الثعلب دونك
محمد
هذه الحلقه كان برفقه ثعلب ثعلب اشتم
رائحه الاكل فجاء متسللا من اجل ان يحظى
ببعض الطعام كذلك بعض الحيوانات الاخرى
واحيانا للاسف اعتداءات بعض الناس الذين
لا يتفهمون ربما خصوصيه ما يقدمه محمد علي
الطالبي او او عن طريق هذه النافذه التي
ينقل منها الصور الحقيقه جميله وجميله جدا
عن تونس ويبذل مجهود ارائع ورائع جدا حلمك
بعد دليل او الدور وهذه المغامره الفريده
لنقل حتى في العالم العربي ما هو حلمك
محمد علي الحلم خلينا نقول خلينا نبدا من
تونس نحاول نعرف بتونس في جميع انحاء
السيرتو في الغرب خليه ياخذوا فكره على
العالم العربي المطبخ في تونس المطبخ خطر
ملك فيكش في القناه بتاعي على اليوتيوب
دليل او دورس نعملو المطبخ التونسي بنسبه
50 40%
ونحاولوا نعرفوا بالمطبخ اللي موجود في
العالم العربي لانه غني موجود فيه الكثير
خلي الغرب يعرفوا ما هو المطبخ العربي
بالاساس بطبيعه انا قاعد نسوق في المطبخ
التونسي
ونعملوا اطباق مغاربه يا تونسه ليبيه
جزائريه نمشيو للمشرق السعوديه لبنان
ننتشر نحاولو نعرفوا قد ما النجموا
بالمطبخ العربي خاطر كيما قلت هو ثري
وموجود فيه الكثير وعريق
اشكال الاطباق الحقيقه لذيذه ولذيذه جدا
رغم انها احيانا ربما صعبه التطبيق داخل
المطاعم فما بالك في الطبيعه وفي ربما
ظروف مناخيه قد تكون صعبه هذه تجربه دليل
او الدور او محمد علي طالبي الجميله التي
انطلقت من بين الجدران من هذا المطعم
اطعمه الخاص به نحو الطبيعه اعزائي
جميل واحنا بنتمنى له كل التوفيق للشيف
محمد شو براسه اليوم رح يعمل في احضان
الطبيعه
ما هو اول طبق سوف تنجزه في احلال ان شاء
الله بحلول شهر رمضان ان شاء الله فما فما
اطباء قاعدين نحضر فيهم اول طبق الحقيقه
سؤال ما تصورتوش نعمل حاجه تخص رمضان ما
نعرفش البلاد العربيه
اذا سيكون تبقى رمضاني بامتياز اعزائي في
احضان الطبيعه شكرا جزيلا لكم احلام
العبدلي مراسله صباح العربيه والشيف محمد
طالبي شكرا